this video is brought to you by
brilliance you're gonna learn more about
brilliant later in today's video but if
you'd like to learn more about them
right now get a brilliant at org forward
slash buyer graphics and also find a
link in the description below Benjamin
Franklin was one of the founding fathers
of the United States of America you
probably knew that one every single
American has been taught these stories
of his accomplishments since elementary
school and it's hard to go anywhere in
the US without eventually being reminded
of Ben Franklin in Philadelphia there's
the Ben Franklin Bridge Franklin
Institute and statues of his likeness
all over the city his face is also on
the $100 bill there was so much respect
for him in the United States they're
saying anything negative is practically
treasonous but on today's biographic
they're not gonna hold back on all of
the details about how Ben Franklin was a
bit of a mad lat
[Music]
Benjamin Franklin was born on January
the 17th 1706 in Boston Massachusetts
his father
Josiah Franklin came to the colonies in
1682 from Northampton Sharon tea made
candles and SOPA for a living
Josiah Franklin fathered 16 children he
had seven with his first wife and child
in England and nine with the second wife
by a folia once he came to America this
he can imagine raising 17 children on
the candlemaker salary was not easy
money was incredibly tight in their
household Ben Franklin went to grammar
school for just two years because he had
to leave to work in his father's candle
business Ben Franklin's parents were so
poor they sold him into indentured
servitude to their oldest son James in
case you weren't aware of how indentured
servitude works Ben Franklin was an
unpaid slave to his own brother until
his labor repaid the debt
James had started his own printmaking
business ends published a newspaper
called the New England Courant Ben's
free room and board also counted against
him for most of his younger years he was
not allowed to earn an income Franklin
try to earn money by starting a side
hustle
he used the printers to self publish his
writing then he would stand in the
middle of the streets and recite his
ballads and his poems out loud trying to
sell paper copies to be fully passed by
however he was a novice without a proper
education so this never really made
enough income to support him franklin
then tried to get married at age 19 to a
woman named Deborah Reed at the time
when a man got married they received a
dowry from the woman's father which
would have helped him pay off his debt
at first he thought he could live
together with Reed's parents but once
her father found out that Franklin was
an indentured servant he retracted his
permission for the two of them to marry
after rejecting Ben Franklin Deborah
Reed's parents arranged a marriage for
her to a man named John Rogers however
it turns out that Franklin wasn't the
only one who is eyeing Deborah's dowry
Rogers lied about having a job and he
was actually unemployed he spent all the
money and got them both into a massive
amount of debt one of trauma rod Reza's
friends her englands came to visit and
was shocked to see that he had a wife
because he was already legally married
back in the UK after being exposed John
Rogers jumps on the next boat back to
England obviously this was a disaster
and Deborah Reed could not get a divorce
because he wasn't around to signed the
paperwork meanwhile Ben Franklin was
enjoying his life as a bachelor in his
autobiography he wrote about what sounds
like a sex addiction the hard to be gay
passion of my youth had hurried me
frequently into intrigues with low women
that fell in my way by the time then
franklin and deborah reed reunited he
had gotten another woman pregnant out of
wedlock he showed up with a baby who he
called William no one knows the identity
of this mystery woman or why she
abandons their child
Deborah Reid though was just happy to
have Franklin back and she agreed to
help raise William since Reid never got
a divorce they could not get legally
married they went on to have two more
children together and live as common-law
husband and wife
[Music]
once Franklin completed his sentence of
servitude it only made sense for him to
take everything he learned from his
brother James and open up his own
printing business in order to accomplish
that he had to travel to England to
purchase expensive printing equipment
and sailed back to Boston Franklin was
still broke but he was able to get an
investor to help with the start-up costs
however once he was in London his
investor backed out leaving him stranded
Franklin managed to get back to the
United States but he decided to leave
Boston in favour of Philadelphia he
began printing the Pennsylvania Gazette
in 1728 he didn't waste any time making
friends and joined a club called the
Junsu Club together they established a
library similar to what was already
available to the public back in England
even though the Johnson Club was already
getting this project together
Franklin would often claim that he was
the first one to create a library in the
United States although himself that lie
has been circulated so many times that
it has even found its way into history
books another one of the achievements
that Ben Franklin is mistakenly credited
with is publishing the first Almanac in
the United States his Poor Richard's
Almanack premiered in 1733 and it became
the second most printed book besides the
Bible however he actually stole this
idea and took all of the credit again
the Leeds family of New Jersey had been
publishing a Farmers Almanac since 1689
which was 17 years before Ben Franklin
was even born
Franklin thought that their business was
thriving and he decided that he wanted
to steal the business model but the
needs family was already far more
established and popular than he was
young Franklin didn't stand a chance
that is until he decided to destroy the
family's reputation Ben Franklin began a
rumor that the family's patriarch Titan
Leeds was a Satanist and
he published a prediction that he would
die in 1733 Franklin also went on to
publish more defamatory stories about
the Leeds family in the Philadelphia
Gazette just two years later is 1735 a
story spreads that mother Leeds gave
birth to a hideous demonic creature
called the Jersey Devil this permanently
ruined the family's reputation to the
point where the family business could
not recover so now you might be
wondering what why didn't the Leeds
family just sue the hell out of Ben
Franklin well right around the same time
the US courts had decided that
newspapers and print publications should
have freedom of speech even if the words
they printed could not be proven to be
true this idea is what eventually
developed into the First Amendment of
the US Constitution journalists who are
put on a pedestal of having a high
degree of ethics and most people trusted
that they would do their due diligence
before publishing a story just a few
years later in 1737 Ben Franklin got the
job as Postmaster General of
Philadelphia the postal system in the
colonies was already run by the British
crown post it was common for the major
newspaper publishers of each city to be
in charge of the mail since they were
already delivering papers to subscribers
according to the historic records from
the US postal service Franklin could
choose to not deliver any competing
newspapers this essentially gave him a
monopoly over information being sent
throughout Philadelphia keep in mind
this at the time Philadelphia was the
largest city and it was also the
nation's capital with this tremendous
amount of power he could make people
believe anything you want it now just
before we get into some of Franklin's
less than original inventions let me
tell you a bit about brilliance
brilliance her a science learning
platform that allow you to learn through
active learning which summed up is
basically the opposite of that feeling
of reading a complex paragraph without
some principle and then just have no
idea what's going on even when you've
read it 10 times and it's still just a
blur you don't even remember what you
read active learning is the opposite of
that and that's what brilliant is about
basically they give you a short
paragraph to read a concept for you to
grasp and then they give you a question
on it immediately afterwards so you're
applying that knowledge immediately and
this is an incredibly effective way to
learn now you've heard me talk about
brilliance a bunch they've got lots of
cool stuff on there they got these daily
challenges where every day you can take
five minutes to just go through a
question this is perfect if you're busy
if you're someone like me don't have a
ton of time every day to sit down and do
something but you can
take five minutes a day on your commute
to work or whatever and just do a quick
daily challenges that again bit of
information
quick question underneath and you can
just whip through one of those and it's
a fantastic way to basically grasp a
concept that you didn't think you'd be
able to grasp it's a really effective
way to learn also speaking of doing
these on your commute brilliant now have
offline mode so you can get the
brilliant app you can use it offline so
you don't have to use your data or if
you've got a spotty internet connection
if you're on a flight stuff like that it
doesn't matter so if you want to support
bio graphics which is always good of you
and get unlimited access to all of
brilliance in-depth maths and science
courses you can head over to brilliant
double forward slash bio graphics and
get 20% off their annual premium
subscription and let's go back to
Franklin you've probably heard that Ben
Franklin discovered electricity as the
story goes he went outside with a key
tied to a kite string during a lightning
storm many modern-day historians now
believe that this story was a work of
fiction other scientists were already
experimenting with electricity years
before he did Peter Collinson was
actually the man who showed Ben Franklin
a functional electric tube which sparked
his interest in science after this point
Franklin began his own experiments with
electricity however keep in mind that he
only had two years of elementary school
education and was self-taught through
reading books
unlike Peter Collinson Franklin had no
knowledge of physics he was so clueless
that he published information that
electricity was actually a fluid despite
not really knowing what he was talking
about Ben Franklin made a huge public
spectacle about his discovery of
electricity he decided to show how he
could stop a Turkey's heart with an
electric shock because well I guess
that's not creepy or anything then he
wanted to go on and cook the entire
turkey with electrocution as well but in
the midst of trying to demonstrate this
he actually electrocuted himself and
passed out on the floor in front of a
crowd of people instead of realizing
that Ben Franklin was incapacitated
people were still very impressed and
this allowed him to develop a reputation
of being a scientist he went on to
supposedly invent several other things
like the Franklin stove which was
actually a copy of the design of a
fireplace at the Louvre in Paris and
further the College of optometrists says
serious doubts that he
we invented bifocal I glasses the list
of examples goes on and on
the deeper you research the more you
realized that Ben Franklin may not have
invented anything and that all of his
ideas most likely came from books and
people that he met he never filed single
patents never registered any copyright
and in his autobiography he claims that
he chose not to do this because he was
such a great guy and wanted to share
these brilliant ideas with the world
without profiting the reality was that
if he filed a patent for an idea that
wasn't his he was just asking to get
sued even though he never made any money
from these inventions Benjamin Franklin
was still a successful businessman by
the time he was in his forties his
employees were running the newspaper
without him and he was able to focus on
his position as Postmaster General he
would travel around the country for
public speaking engagements with members
of the British Parliament when he was 51
years old Benjamin Franklin moved to
England in order to negotiate on behalf
of the colonists of Pennsylvania
Franklin spent the next several years
living in London with his son William he
began to make friends with members of
the British aristocracy this led him to
become a part of a group called the
Hellfire Club which was a secret society
of upper-class men who liked to discuss
philosophy politics and the occult
members met as empty monasteries and
churches to hold black masses and orgies
according to records the members wore
robes similar to monks and tried to
perform magic spells there were
thirty-six separate allegations that Ben
Franklin was indeed a part of the
Hellfire Club under the code name
brother Benjamin of cookin there's also
significant evidence in the form of
letters written by Franklin that proves
he was very good friends with the
founder Sir Francis Dashwood despite the
overwhelming amount of evidence of any
American Historians have tried to make
up excuses pheromones deny his
involvement in the club Ben Franklin's
private life was even darker than we can
ever imagine in 1998 a group was
attempting to renovate his house in
London when they discovered the bones of
at least 15 people buried in his
basement John Wayne Gacy style Oh
six of those bodies were young children
there was even a baby the bones showed
signs that they had been dissected with
their limbs chopped and drilled to make
them easier to carry down into the
crawlspace historians were baffled by
this scene that clearly looks like the
work of a serial killer they scrambled
to find a rational explanation as to why
their beloved founding father would have
done this they then decided to blame
on William Hewson who was a friend of
Franklin's Hewson was studying blood and
he became known as the father of
hematology at the time it was illegal
for doctors to dissect cadavers because
it was considered to be disrespectful
and it went against Christian beliefs
and burial rites but doctors and
scientists they continued to do so in
the name of science there is no
documentation proving that this theory
about an anatomy school is true and it
is simply speculation if Hewson was
responsible for this it would still make
Ben Franklin complicit in grave robbing
some historians are quick to jump to
Franklin's defense saying that it's
possible that he had no idea that
William Hewson had done this but if we
learned anything from the story of John
Wayne Gacy the smell of 15 bodies in the
windowless basement would have been an
overwhelming scent so there's probably
no way Franklin could have missed that
Benjamin Franklin moved back to the
colonies in 1775 during the break out of
the Revolutionary War his son William
Franklin publicly announced his loyalty
to England and was banished from ever
returning to the colonies again so he
continued living in London even though
he publicly supported the Americas it
would seem that Ben and his son were
actually on the same page author and
historian Richard Deacon wrote a book
called a history of the British Secret
Service where he presents compelling
evidence that Ben Franklin was working
as a double agents number 72 when he
returned to the colonies the Americans
believed that he was giving them vital
information about England's to help in
the war effort but Deakin discovered
that the British archives actually had
copies of every single transmission in
reality Franklin was only telling the
Americans what the British wanted them
to hear in 1776 the American
Revolutionary War was won and the
British colonies became the United
States the Declaration of Independence
it was created by a committee of five
men with Thomas Jefferson being the main
writer according to the Franklin
Institute then Franklin's only
contribution was to check for spelling
errors even though he was secretly
spying for England's Franklin was happy
to take some of the glory he made his
signature on the Declaration of
Independence nearly as large and
obnoxious as John Hancock's just one
month later though he wanted to move
back to Europe he left the colonies and
became the new American ambassador of
France
[Music]
in 1777 Ben Franklin began his new life
in Paris at this point he was a
celebrity and it was well known that he
was one of America's founding fathers
the French had helped during the
American Revolution so the excitement of
the victory was still in the air people
were also invested in reading the
stories about everyone involved the
French Revolution it was only a few
years away in 1789 French women thought
that these stories they were exciting
and they imagined American men to be
brave and heroic even at 71 years olds
Ben Franklin had no problem impressing
the ladies with his stories and he
started living his best life at this
point he had no longer any filter he
began to earn a reputation of being
gluttonous lecherous and partying really
hot when John Adams went to visit
Franklin and Paris he came back
disgusted by how he was wasting taxpayer
dollars on his extravagant lifestyle
Thomas Jefferson also wrote about
Franklin I've marked in particularly in
the company of women where he loses all
power over himself and becomes almost
frenzied even though the founding
fathers were trying to get Franklin's
you check himself before he wrecked
himself he responded to all of his
haters by writing this poem so though I
robbed you of a kiss sweeter than the
ambrosial do why are you so angry as my
bliss has it all impoverished you this
wild lifestyle that wasn't just reserved
for pirate parties though Franklin's
next-door neighbor was a wealthy
businessman named at Massey of brillo
and a joy and his wife Madame Brillon
was a famous hop score Platt just like
many other French women Madame brilliant
thoughts that Franklin was very
impressive and they began to have an
affair she was in her 30s and she didn't
seem to minds that Franklin was in his
70s for some strange reason Franklin
thought it was necessary to make Madame
brilliant sign a contract on the terms
of their affair apparently Monsour
brilliant had absolutely no idea that
Franklin was sleeping with his wife
because he was invited over to dinner at
their house twice a week there were a
countless number of affairs with other
women including the widow of the famous
photographer el Vettes and Catherine de
ligniville d'autricourt our she declined
claiming that she was still in love with
her late husband and that she felt it
would be disrespectful to his memory
unfortunately the Ben Franklin probably
didn't restrain himself until after
Deborah's death
Affairs when he was 39 years old he
wrote a letter to a young man who wanted
advice on how to deal with the sex
addiction
Franklin recommended that he should
start having secret affairs with older
women because they were more experienced
discreet and willing to treat younger
men very well he also mentions that
after menopause
there is no hazard of children when you
go through all of the very specific
details he gives him that letter it's
obvious that Franklin was speaking from
experience after the other founding
fathers saw his true colors word began
to spread that Franklin was actually a
lecherous old man most people felt that
this was acceptable considering all of
his other accomplishments and of course
he came up with excuses for his poor
behavior in one of his essays he wrote
that he developed a method of trying to
see if it was possible for a human being
to actually achieve perfection his list
of 13 virtues were as follows
temperance silence order resolution
frugality industry sincerity justice
moderation cleanliness tranquility and
chastity Franklin claims that he would
make attempts to improve his personality
only to realize that the harder he tried
to be good at one thing he would begin
to lack in other aspects of his life he
concluded that it's not possible for
someone to ever be perfect so if can't
be perfect I even tried to be a good
person right
[Music]
for the rest of Benjamin Franklin's life
he continued to indulge in whatever he
wanted he eventually contracted a
painful condition known as the gout
which usually only happens from drinking
too much alcohol and eating the wrong
things during his recovery he wrote a
fake conversation with his disease
through this we find out that in his
later years the only exercise he got in
a day was the walk from his carriage to
a restaurant and then back again
the rest of his time was spent lounging
around drinking tea eating reading books
and spending time with the ladies
Benjamin Franklin died at the ripe old
age of 84 contrary to popular belief he
did not have syphilis which is miracle
considering that he slept with nearly
everything that moved
he had pleurisy when he died which is a
disease of the lung the years after his
death the only evidence that people
cared about Ben Franklin's legacy came
from his self-published autobiography
they believed everything he said and
took his word as gospel the hero worship
that Benjamin Franklin is now ingrained
in American history people want to
believe that this genius polymath was
one of the masterminds behind the
founding of the nation and an Americans
became proud to have him represent their
country whether you love him or hate him
there is no denying that he made an
impact today there are statues museums
libraries schools and entire towns named
after Benjamin Franklin in the u.s. if
you were alive to see all this today he
would probably smile because just like
everything else in his life he got
exactly what he wanted so I really hope
you found that video interesting if you
did please do give us a thumbs up below
and don't forget to subscribe we got
brand new videos four times a week also
please do check out brilliance there's a
link below and as always thank you for
watching
you
[Music]